-Bebe, you're up first,
so, why don't you come up here
and let's see
what you're gonna play.
Uh, pull the mic down.
[ Spins ]
"Nonsense Karaoke" okay.
-Oh, boy.
-♪ This is Nonsense Karaoke ♪
♪ This is Nonsense Karaoke ♪
-Alright, this one's tricky.
You're gonna have to sing
a well-known song,
but the lyrics have been
replaced with total nonsense.
What song will it be?
-Aah! This is nerve-wracking.
-You can do it.
Well, I think you can.
Oh.
-Okay. Okay.
-"Only Girl (In the World),"
but none of those lyrics
will be on the screen,
these are all made-up words.
There's your mic, over there.
-Okay.
-And I installed a, I installed
a Rihanna fan right here
so that you could get a little
bit of the wind effect.
-[ Laughs ]
-You'll enjoy it.
-Okay. So --
-Bebe Rexha, whenever you're --
-Oh.
-Whenever you're ready.
-I'm nervous. Okay.
-Don't be.
We got you, Bebe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ready?
-I don't know.
-Ready, you got this,
you got this.
-I guess so.
-Bebe Rexha, go!
[Intro to Rihanna's "I'm the
Only (Girl In the World)" plays]
-Whoa, alright. Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Lotta wind. Lotta wind.
-Here we go, one, two --
-♪ Rub-a-dubby-a-dubby ♪
♪ I'm eatin' hot fries ♪
♪ Sippin' on some bubbly ♪
♪ On a water slide ♪
-Genius writing.
-♪ Did you watch
"My Name is Earl"? ♪
♪ I forgot to DVR it
last night ♪
♪ A snake with
broken legs on it ♪
♪ Constitutional convention
delight ♪
Oh, my God!
♪ So could you help me steal ♪
♪ My favorite hoodie
back from that girl? ♪
♪ I left my other one
up in the club ♪
♪ I find that I don't like
impressionist art ♪
♪ Homely petulant squirrel ♪
♪ I don't like vegetables
that come in a can ♪
♪ For Halloween I dress up
as Peter Pan ♪
♪ But as the prisoner of
Azkaban-an-an ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
-Wow! Wow!